hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to civilization now we
got surrounded on both sides here which
probably means that we're gonna die in a
horrible horrible way but that's not
what Teddy would do teddy without geez
Teddy would rally his troops and get out
there and fight these douchebags so
that's what I'm gonna do maybe I don't
know military tradition that sounds good
clear a barbarian outpost isn't that
what I did or is that the thing that
makes it able to do that
I forget which but I'm gonna figure out
how to fight these guys so I got my do
there but I don't want to go out and
attack cuz well you know I probably
should ha we're gonna get you happy baby
to be able to move because maybe we'll
heal over the turn considering they're
gonna like you know fortify or whatever
yeah [ __ ]
well we're [ __ ] I don't know what
we're gonna do but you need to build a
goddamn farm they're gonna they're gonna
raise our farms I know that alright next
turn come on bring it on hey hey you
want to fight me Oh me you want to fight
me oh I don't think so oh I don't think
so I think they're afraid to attack me
because I'm fortified in the city which
means that they would have a severe just
no come back come back no oh god I did
not know that we left him mmm that's no
good well city is undefended in there's
barbarians on the horizon so whenever
you guys feel like coming back I should
have waited for the other barbarians to
be done oh oh okay
fortify alrighty then we're just gonna
sit here and wait uh-oh ever wet it clay
and then left it as if there would be
breakfast by chance and fortune hmm okay
alright so we got oh our barbarians
finished oh hell yeah we can raise hell
on these guys being at the Hanging
Gardens whoo plantation
nice yes yes we need that we need that
so badly oh we need that so badly okay
we're gonna get that we're doing good I
could make another dude but you know for
now I'm gonna focus I think we got this
handled
I'm gonna build a settler these guys are
brand-new and fresh we're gonna get a
victory on these a-holes we're gonna
strip why or what which way did you go
okay whatever you know and I'm gonna
assume that you know what's best and you
guys can't hit him cuz you'll die
already then how's everything going on
in Charleston and how do I rename things
dammit dammit I don't think this would
rename the cities I wanted to name him
like [ __ ] Tynan alright next turn
okay you guys bring it on Bing bong
bring it on all day long what did you do
is being the only one who knows you're
afraid Oh why'd you do that ah great
general I don't want that God they've
owned my farm you pillaged it why'd you
do that dick we're gonna victory on your
face oh god they pillaged the farm and
then they got health back the a-holes
it's what barbarians do their dicks
I get a major victory caboose key oh god
that ah
Frick you just a little Frick little
flicky Frick a flick of Frick in your
face all right this doesn't look good
but we might kill him but maybe I should
go these guys first cuz they're gonna
kill him you're dead now oh oh oh what's
that ha ha oh you're dead and your horse
he's gonna go swimming in the ocean ok
bye alright then well we got bad but
it's still pillaged which is bad okay
you guys need to fortify until healed
what are we building Oh we're building a
settler okay shudders key whoo
how do I keep getting rumbles and
jumbles oh you grew cuz you got so much
food hell yeah
get that crap if you don't get that crap
I'm gonna be very pissed I should have
made my other thing over there but
whatever
okay fortified till healed her
oh yeah there's more Scouts we need to
kill them but not now we're gonna wait
we're gonna wait and eventually I will
have lived without love not one without
water
oh well that's depressing okay thanks
for having some insightful commentary on
what the hell we're doing here or we
need to mine because we got these two
stone things right by our place and we
need to get those mines going because
that's gonna make production goats whoa
okay they're healed okay good so I'm
gonna send I'm gonna send these dudes
over to Charleston can you just go to
Charleston please a little bit of wood
okay so you're gonna just fortify
because I feel like keeping you nearby
an unmet player is finished building the
world wonder of Stone Edge oh good job
you put a bunch of rocks on top of rocks
Oh way to go you are an amazing species
or civilization whatever you are I like
to think that my people aren't exactly
human are you just stay there keep
Washington safe but Babbitt aboot Bowie
about maybe to move yourself in a hole
quit digging oh I don't know what that
has to do with anything we were doing
there but you fortify there or a fortify
till healed or no you just fortify you
know what actually never mind you I
don't know do something do something
with your life man explore the southern
tip here and stay there we need wood
like bronze working but we've been
working on this horseback-riding I'm
gonna finish it
cuz the Rough Riders will ride again any
more housing Charleston needs more
housing to keep growing if this
continues we'll have difficulty gaining
new citizens well I don't have any
builders so how about you screw yourself
okay I don't have any builders we're out
of builders I got one settler coming in
and he's gonna get that craft
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah this crap over
there it's charming well what about this
one it's breathtaking oh but they get
Wales over there okay you're gonna
settle over there we're gonna get Wales
and we're gonna get craft forget all
this [ __ ] or Hanging Gardens why do I
want that I don't want that that sounds
like [ __ ] a bunch of ass if you ask
me ah
we need more builders what are you doing
it's 4:00 to 5:00 what are you doing
4:45 next Hey oh it's the glass place
spiritually as well as physically bigger
than a man on foot this is true I mean I
can't argue with that a strong economy
begins with a strong well-educated
workforce
I completely agree now whip them into
shape and get the factories working I
want a bunch of sweatshops
I want no breaks they work 16 hours a
day they get two hours of sleep and then
force-feed them for the rest of the the
six hours of the day that's free time I
guess okay I need a been planning gonna
get yeah we need a lot of builders
because we just need to be able to
improve stuff wait oh yeah
confirm okay I am okay you found a city
there you do that thing boink
Boston oh and it's cold it's just like
Boston that's adorable oh that's weird
is that America the representative of
what America is I mean I can't argue
with it it kind of looks like America
they even got the monument right that in
there okay fine I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna argue
ron's working yeah sure I'm just gonna
go for the cheap ones all right we need
to build something here
but oh they do have a bit of production
that's really good oh nice nice we can
make a [ __ ] ship we can make a ship
I'll make that galley oh hell yeah go
say hi to the craft then go say hi to
everybody else in the entire world heck
it can go here do the do the quarry yes
Oh smash that [ __ ] alright so that's
good we need to build something else
there a granary that sounds good we
could do that I could definitely do that
I could get behind that Washington's
gonna be great
everything else is gonna be garbage a
Washington's gonna be great oh wow holy
[ __ ] you really smashed into that
sumbitch I can appreciate that we had
recently gained advanced knowledge in
City Planning creating districts in our
cities can be much more powerful and
lucrative than simple improvements like
farms and mines ah throws I thought I
was doing great I was applying my old
knowledge of civilization to the new Oh
fine districts okay can I make this the
the sweatshop district creating a
lasting legacy because bronze will last
for thousands of years I suppose but
then it ended you know the Bronze Age
okay I can make a pasture nice I want to
make a pasture hell yeah all right we
need shipbuilding huh I mean if I build
do tanaan it's gonna take too long
anyway
might as well you let me open the tree
what are we looking for here mathematics
we need oh we need currency we need
writing okay we definitely need writing
so let's get writing out of the way so
that we can go go go you build that you
do that thing habu ski
oh man that poor cow you just clobbered
him would you do that it was a lovely
cow Oh God no either fine I got
defenders over there I don't have any
defenders in Boston though ah okay this
shipbuilding city that's gonna die
no I don't care Oh where did that come
from where the [ __ ] did that come from
I'm gonna kill that dad holy [ __ ] yes I
am
ooh I'm gonna get you you're gonna be
dead oh yeah yeah yeah you're gonna be
dead don't holy [ __ ] yeah you go over
there and kill them dead oh hi oh hello
yeah
Queen of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Ireland and soon dare I say
the Empire oh my goodness yes excellent
to meet you Victoria they they
definitely changed the art style on this
one
let's see Teddy Roosevelt's a gentleman
through and through maybe I don't know I
can't remember if it was actually a
gentleman or not but would you like to
visit our city
oh well huh I'm glad you know thanks for
being okay all right you can maybe come
by oh thanks Eureka right oh cool all
you have to do is cross out the wrong
words oh okay
all right then well they visited us and
we didn't even know how to write we were
just a bunch of rampaging goofs all
right so now oh we built the quarry so I
guess we can do masonry I don't give us
a little boost all right we're gonna
take care of our problem here I don't
know how did you find was that them is
that you that you or Zeb barbarians it's
England hi we don't know how to do that
I mean we know how to do that but we've
been too lazy to actually build it
thanks for visiting thank you oh that's
awesome we finally met someone which
means that we're not alone in this world
I just hope it's not only them and I
hope that Gandhi isn't just hiding
around hey douche stop doing that
don't you eat this dick hey Batman how
well that sucked for that guy I did it
it it oh you built a ship you built a
ship oh this [ __ ] we're gonna get
another one
cuz I like that was it campus
okay cool oh we can build spearmen now
nice okay we're just gonna keep this is
gonna be ship ship town
so if England came from over to the
right we need to scout over to the left
here so you have a long trip over that
way all right next I'm gonna wallop the
[ __ ] out of you by yourself
oh no he's firing it out and that sucked
alright we're gonna win you're dead
you're dead caboose key you're dead
you're dead net okay so then you guys
are gonna go well later you're gonna go
over there and then you're gonna fortify
til healed and you're gonna clear that
encampment because we need that gone
what if we build why don't we just build
oh that's how you build a district oh we
could be scientists now why would we do
that
alright fine I'll do that woo woo I like
it I like it okay this one nearby is not
really used so if that's pretty good
yeah well yeah well that's cool you can
actually make city sprawl which which
always makes sense because why would the
city only be congregated in one tile
like cities need to like expand not just
like their boundaries but physically
they should expand that's cool that's a
good feature I like that feature that's
real nice oh they're guarded by
spearmint I think will be a brace we
have obtained greater knowledge in the
art of building static fortifications
building walls around our city each oh I
know do you go right there then you guys
are gonna fortify once you're tired from
that long run concurrency good we need
currency OOP taboo okay keep going
go very far don't go that close to them
why would you do that oh they can't hear
you they're fine Lilla gates you fortify
until healed Ibuki oh my gosh Oh what
happened oh yay finally we can do the
trade route that only took four
bajillion turns all right do Washington
cuz hekia hekia heck addition to
bringing riches to our civilization
this trade route will gradually develop
roads between our cities words allow our
units to no longer be impaired by the
difficult terrain through which they
pass thanks I'm trying to figure out
your accent but I just can't lay a
finger on it
oh that's cool all right we're making
good progress but hopefully this gal is
gonna be able to find someone besides
all the craft oh look at the craft oh
they're hiding oh they're so cute
oh I want to eat them actually I don't
like crap very much I want to pet them
what shall we build which is gonna dig
forever
god it's gonna take so long okay it said
it needed more housings and it said it
needed more amenities so I'm gonna
assume that a granary would be a good
idea here so I'm gonna try for that
all right shabu ski oh no enemy Kellie
oh it's England it's okay the
opportunity has arrived for a change
into a new and more powerful system of
government Wow let us strengthen our
identity and enact more policies to
govern our people cool I'm all about
governing politics is the art of the
possible
the attainable the art of the next-best
okay I don't know if that's true or not
judging by current politics but okay
change governments oh yeah an oligarchy
I do like that an autocracy oh I do like
a classical Republic but I do like to
build fancy things I mean that's pretty
cool ah so many choices this is actually
cool the way they're doing the
government thing here so with our basic
government which is is chiefdom chief
Teddy Roosevelt you know need to do some
other stuff so we're gonna do what
Goodin do you do I want great people or
do I want wonders do I want these weird
things or do I want great people yeah
I'll take great people I like me some
great people okay cool
nice okay BAM
we need trade I do like trade okay
envoys I don't know how that works okay
and then one more general one which I
think I'm going to use as I'm gonna go
for God King I'm a hundred percent going
for God King because I I skipped over
that in the last episode but I really
really wanna be considered daddy rose
enough the god king of America anyway
drama and poetry sure okay
OOP oh you skedaddle that road oh where
you going find more people do ass now I
wanted to find good please accept my
warmest thanks for your kind endeavors
on the continent we share um I don't
know about you but I'm alone on an
island but thank you I don't know
exactly what I'm doing but you're
welcome can I send you an envoy madam I
would like to send a delegation um
gossip items access level can we once I
find someone to gossip about you know
Teddy's go to gossip with you Victoria
but until that happens I got a I got a
gossip about myself and talk about my
shortcomings as if it's somebody else
nothing I would know about that royal
envoy on behalf of the United Kingdom oh
yes
please come by if I knew how to do that
I would send an envoy just licentious
nothing having great possessions but in
having few wants nice again like all the
other quotes in here I don't understand
it because I'm too dumb but I'm assume
it means good hmm I suppose we need the
wheel I mean eventually we'll have the
wheel right eventually someday we'll get
it who is you who is you hello friend
Lisbon
who's Lisbon want to say hi yeah come on
bring all your weapons to the shore
that's how we say hello to
hello Lisbon lone Island just by
yourself why are you why are you all
alone why are you so alone I feel bad no
all right you guys go get him go get em
buckaroo knees go get him bucks
Bucky dues Eureka nice
all right kill him kill him dead I don't
remember this being here before but kill
him dead you'll eventually win okay so
now we got two galleys so I'm gonna make
this galley go whereare maybe I should
have just set it to automate exploration
which would have been smarter hey can i
no never mind how do I say hi to you
hello oh it's a city-state oh god I'm an
idiot
it's a of course the dotted line ah god
I totally forgot that's a city-state and
that is not a civilization okay you go
over there then actually you just
automated exploration because my god
this is just ridiculous now
how about Kiki oh no your face it got
exploded and this is mine now by the way
thank you gold please over these would
be great tiles we're a long way from
growth so ping pong okay that's good
Harrelson us understand er filthier
under a worm-eating sleek lunch new
lawyer ha ha
and stuff right maybe maybe a little bit
of fear is coursing through my grundle
but it's okay Harold sigurðsson stands
before you a Viking unlike in eNOS I'm
sorry this is so offensive
hey the seas I'm not gonna stop I'm just
gonna double down on the offensiveness
and lands if ever noon ha are you freed
okay it's an honor to meet you have
travels fear and weed I'm so sorry but
I've never seen your capital tell me of
it
whoa geez I'm sorry let's talk I want to
trade Victoria I have gossip gossip
Victoria okay fine then right then
before defying till he'll but we found
somebody hello
oh yes hellooo ah you also have a
granary very nice and hopefully there's
more of you out there idea for it to
just be the three of us in a weird love
triangle for Victoria here that would be
odd or a love triangle for Harold
Hartman Harald Hardrada hurled hard
Rhonda okay so we've met two people and
we didn't die from the Barbarian so
that's actually pretty good
I think I'm actually gonna play one more
episode here I'm gonna try to expand my
horizons to the entire map that's a bit
of a lofty goal but I just want to have
an idea of where everything is and then
hopefully the island of America will
rise and be supreme so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]